regardez à gauche on y est on est chez
nous
il était une fois un homme méchant qui
s'appelait Jack le peintre et il était
tellement débile que les villageois ont
craqué et ont décidé de le
[Musique]
diable à hippie de Jack et lui a offert
une lanterne
[Musique]
restera éteinte alors vos enfants
n'auront rien à craindre et qu'est-ce
qui se passerait si on l'avait rallumé
alors vous êtes foutu
au 12 coups de minuit Jacques pourrait
rester dans notre monde pour toujours
il donne vie aux décorations d'Halloween
et se crée une armée il est presque
minuit il faut trouver Jack ce sera tous
les jours Halloween
je savais pas faire du vélo c'est une
blague mes parents m'ont toujours appris
que les livres me conduirait ou je
voulais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]